All right, welcome to another Zoom call, remember in between Zoom calls, if you can find your questions answered on the member site.
Or on the daily blogs that we put out to do look there also so you don't have to wait.
Remember also that we have a Monday Zoom call down as well at noon, central time of Monday. That's what they am.
She will be answering questions if she gets questions in that she doesn't know the answer she asked me.
Our office is right next to each other so.
Jump on that one, you can jump on either one of these Zoom calls so let's start with her questions.
Any suggestions the last few days I have had a lot of pain in my shoulder area to the point.
Be it being hard to sit up or to lean forward.
Also have discomfort cough in my chest.
So always with any symptom that you have you always want to try to ask the question why isn't there if the symptom is due to inflammation because of the cancer itself.
If the treatment of that would be a little bit different that if the symptom was due to an injury versus the treatment that was due to a virus or a bacterial infections.
You always want to dig to ask the question why this is related to the cancer you can really pinpoint it definitely related to the cancer then definitely with pain you want to look at anti inflammatory type things.
In the flavonoid category the curcumin increasing curcumin also think of doing some topical CBD or topical come free Sam something like that would be good to use.
If the pain is due to inflammation in the lungs that is referred pain to another area then then again you would look at other different sources of treating the inflammation and lungs or if the virus or the bacterial infections of discomfort or cough in the chest.
When we have cancer we tend to jump to conclusion sometimes correct sometimes incorrect that every symptom we have is from spread or growth or increase in cancer or you can be completely unrelated as well.
I just had a few people enter in when you register your to get on a zoom call and everybody except one person put their full name so I can see their names that is helpful to me.
So that we know who's on the zoom call so if you can the person that just put their initial if you can put your name that will be helpful just your first name so we don't.
Next question so longer one what do you recommend for help in healing the blood braid barrier and braid inflammation I'm really at with end I use a variety of forms of magnesium including topical application.
Have taken all the supplements you suggested curcumin risk baritone vitamin D Omega's Burberry and so for a phase magnesium can be helpful for headaches as well eGCG Bacopa who proceed a in the past so for a phase definitely makes my pain worse I have had two memory formulas and so recognize the Bacopa it's in both the organic India.
In the memory formula and this other neural peak will look for a formula cutator who presented a to muscle test I have had a new blue shield plug in units to I think these are to help block eMFs and to help with personal devices for months with the improvement symptoms.
I also taken a fermented horse tail recommended by Lloyd Burrell Lloyd Burrell is a specialist in eMF and radiation helping with that I have no wireless in my home when I am still highly reactive to my computer I sleep with an R at canopy.
Would you ask doctors if there's any additional recommendations okay so there's a video on the blog if you search braid inflammation it it's a video that I created because I gave a talk to some doctors about damage to the microglial cells of the braid and it's all information on microglial priming.
So what a person has such braid inflammation like this yes it's a blood braid barrier issue so understand you have a barrier that blocks different that literally wraps around the blood vessels of the brain and it's made up of a certain glial cell called an asteriside so asterisides wrap around the blood vessels of the brain and they help prevent larger chemicals and bad things.
That may be circulating in the blood from getting into the brain because if they get into the brain cavity they can cause all sorts of inflammation and damage and our brains kind of important so we have a barrier called the blood brain barrier that's made up of these asterisides now asterisides can be damaged and that can that can basically we can the barrier is not existent at that site if you have a damaged asteriside.
And things can get across the blood braid barrier the really the question should be rephrased it's not something I do to help heal the blood braid barrier because there's really nothing there's different nutrients and eating right that possibly can help heal asterisides but really there's no research on the healing of asterisides so when you have a damaged blood braid barrier
then it's it's the damage to the brain cells that is the issue so you end up with damage to these microglial cells which is called microglial primate and there's been a ton of research on this in the last 10 years because all this money had been poured into brain inflammation research because of the professional football players lawsuits with them.
with post-concussive syndrome so we get to benefit from that research and the research is showing the number one thing that you could do to help decrease damage to microglial cells are the list of things you have have a parenthesis here the flavonoids and it far exceeds any benefit for any drug which was kind of shocking to the medical community.
it was nutritional, curcumin, resveratrol and stuff like that now people that have damaged microglial cells tend to be much more sensitive to EMFs now the other thing that a person could do with this is very very very slow and very very mild exercise but you need to start exercising and I said that to this person and they said oh there's no way I can't I can't exercise you have to kind of push yourself a little bit you need to start exercising
it's a very difficult road to get through that because but it's there's no other way it's it's not easy there's certain things you cannot do so you have to be taking the curcumin, resveratrol and all those kind of things you have to start on an exercise program but this has to do with chemo brain too so don't think that this question is only for this one person anybody that's taking chemo that has any sort of chemo brain
the answer is the same and the answer is also the same that anybody that has any sort of neurological degeneration so you have any neuro degeneration starting meeting early dementia Parkinson's or MS type symptoms it all fits into this exact same category so the it is the flavonoids that I listed and it is mild exercise but doing it very regularly
and then you have got to absolutely baddish alcohol for your diet you cannot drink any alcohol and you have to get out of gluten free diet so even if gluten is nothing to do with driving your cancer which rarely does act as a driver
gluten is highly inflammatory to the brain you have gluteomorphine receptors that fire to the brain also it'd be best if you could get off dairy dairy as case you have case you have more feed receptors that fire to the brain as well so I'll add this question as I have a lot of other questions but off of gluten off of dairy mild exercise
in you know continue with the flavonoids this is for any neuro degeneration problems if you have a failure member that's got early Parkinson's or any early dementia type symptoms it's the same thing
next questioner this is I had to kind of piece this question together because this person said photos and stuff but I was not going to post those photos but he had very low energy last week
random sharpshooting pains in he calls Prometheus this person such a great attitude of life this is a giant mass that he has that we're trying to deal with he has sharpshooting pains in Prometheus he says is this a good thing
well I do have an article good paid bad paid with cancer the answer to something like this honestly is I don't know I don't know if this is a good thing or not if you're running the right and you have pain in the cancer usually you think that's a good thing something is happening to that
but if it's just sharpshooting pains any random time that might not be a good thing we've heard red or purple color into the skin means dead cells is this correct
yes well red and purple color into the skin it's an increase in homo hemociderin which is a breakdown of red blood cells that's where you get bruised
so again that could be a good thing bad thing as well so could be a good thing that there's cells that are died and it's also red blood cells that are died
and the hem is breaking down and that's what's causing the discoloration of the bruised blood but it could be a bad thing that there's actually blockage to blood vessels and there's damage to blood vessels
so we just don't know the answer to that either
for the first time in a month this person just started under our care they're purging black chunks off the tumor that is typically a very good thing
and the purple color will be down the collarbone that's again related to the third question there we just don't know if that's good or bad at this point
David's recent bone marrow biopsy showed 3% blasts this is a leukemia patient to the doctors qualifies as remission and they're taking steps toward bone marrow transplant
so I deal with bone marrow transplant they try to get you to deploy to remission and then do a bone marrow transplant meeting they feel like there's few enough blood cancer cells in the blood that if they do a bone marrow transplant they have a better chance
if there was zero blasts they'd be better but he's looking like they have a good match because of this they've done a battery of tests one of the results concerns us
this ferritin levels are above 1200 we think and understand the speeds iron overload sometimes it does so this is where usually when you have elevated ferritin like that it's a side of inflammation
and the inflammation is probably due to the chemotherapy so I would not be as concerned about that as you might be
I think it's more inflammatory response to the chemotherapy not necessarily an iron overload
I did recommend Ashley to tell you to there's no harm in trying to take HIV assist which is a product that can help with iron overload
I don't think that that is the case but it certainly wouldn't hurt to try that
we've been looking at hyperbaric chambers and high dose vitamin C I think there I don't think there's any contraindications doing this at this point for him either I think that would be just fine as well
I think Ashley should have told you that too
okay I'm going to get my glasses under this not really but I'm going to closer the scheme screen
I was diagnosed with stage 4 ovarian cancer in March of 2022 I also had surgery at male in March and then six cycles of chemo from April to August here in the cities
I was backed out at male last week and had a CT scan with contrast the oncologist told me it appears that I am in remission oh that's fantastic
do you have a good maintenance drug to offer me a maintenance drug we don't have any drugs but I did get what you're talking about
so I am now in a watch and wait period unfortunately statistically 90 to 95% of stage 4 ovarian cancer patients or experience remission have a relapse within two years
I would like to be in the 5 to 10% yes without the relapse
really my answer to be continue on with what we have you on there's no harm in getting another cheek swap test but if we've done that recently I would just continue on what we have you on
I don't stop doing what got you there I know that chemo and the surgery were a big part of it but certainly the alternative things played a part of it as well so you want to keep doing those things
number one should I stay on my diet yes I will do that I would not make any modifications to your original diet or your original supplements second question unless you did another cheek swap
do I continue to do that I am always yes you continue to do it everything that caught you there now I understand some people when they get in remission they're like pump or peat sake I'm just exhausted doing everything I'm doing I need to just cut back a little bit
well just you need to pray about it decide what you need to cut back on make sure you're not cutting back on your right pumpers
so that's a big no no so I also never connected my right because she did internet so that's just fine there's really nothing been major downloads since April so don't worry about that
additional therapies should I continue the coffee out of us yes I would continue about the frequency then I would continue everything at the frequency that got you there unless it's like okay this is so disruptive I gotta I'm doing daily coffee out of this I gotta drop it down to you know three times a week or something you have that right to do that so I would I would otherwise continue everything else
that that you're doing is there anything else I should ask though I just think that staying on your protocols the best thing to do the right ball just wanted to confirm that you leave it in the plastic tube you don't take it out
this must be a very new patient if you take it out of the plastic tube we got a major problem okay so no you don't take it out of the plastic tube please they don't a lot of people don't have time when they first get their stuff
you gotta get on the membership site and watch you know go to the right page and watch those videos
we get a lot of questions like oh it's beeping is that normal is how close should I have it to you and I know these are you know new people kind of questions but we and you're free to ask them so don't ever you don't get that understanding that I we're bothered by questions but we try to answer all of them others please take a little time and watch some of that information
weight loss started again having a biopsy of bone today please help so you should really have a conversation this person I bow this person who asked this weight loss again it really depends on the amount of weight loss but if you're losing two to three pounds a week and you're eating you know you're still eating just as many calories that's a concern
if you haven't been on the zoom call for a matter of weeks I'll remind you that some studies came out about potatoes so we've always said no to potatoes and what defines a potato or a white potato red potato purple potato pink potato the potatoes are totally different than sweet potatoes and yams sweet potatoes and yams are really a total class different class vegetable
vegetable white potatoes we're talking about so you look up a glycemic index and white potatoes you're going to see they have a very high glycemic index even higher than table sugar that means they break down the glucose faster than table sugar some studies have shown that if you bake them twice we did you bake bake five potatoes and for the weekend you put them in the fridge and then you bake them again to eat them when you bake them twice like that you you greatly reduce the glycemic index doesn't mean that
everybody should be potatoes every day because it still has a fairly high glycemic index but it does make them more okay for people that are especially are in a level of cakexia or close to a level cakexia or maybe they're not cakexic we need the definition of cakexia is they're losing two plus pounds a week no matter what they're eating but start eating some potatoes start eating some complex carbohydrates
I have listed the most of your videos I can find and read the notebook I may have missed it as I am sure it's included the inflow somewhere but when under the bed sheets where exactly is the bulbs supposed to be is it supposed to be directly under stomach or abdomen or sitting next to you thanks so it really depends on the cancer try to have it as close to you as possible yes it can roll five you know three feet away from you you're still going to have some
beneficial effects to it even five six seven feet away you'll have some beneficial effects but it decreases exponentially the farther it is away from you so the closer it is to you the better the closer it is to the cancer the better so if you have breast cancer try to get it up to your chest if you have abdominal type cancer keep it tell it's your tummy and snuggle with the ball so you want to snuggle with the ball snuggle with the ball that's the best way to do it
feeling a little bit light-headed or blurry the last three days I feel like I take my powders and vitamins not sure what is causing the feeling feels like my head but not sure why so if you're I think this was a question for the last week actually what I answered again if you feel light-headed or blurry you want to check your blood sugar levels
if you're blood sugar levels dip with hypoglycemia you could get this feeling if you're going to spike in your blood sugar you could get this feeling good to get a CBC test done to make sure your iron levels are okay but definitely if you feel light-headed or blurry you think of brain inflammation as well
I think this person is asked this question also has diagnosed brain cancer so you want to get back to the flavonoids you want to everything I talked about in that first question really back up here with what you do to decrease brain inflammation regardless of whether you have brain cancer or whether you have Lyme disease or whether you have dementia type things or chemo brain or memory problem
or emotional swings or headaches or light-headed dizziness, blurryness all those are signs of brain inflammation so your ramp up the flavonoids make sure you decrease anything that could call me causing brain inflammation
and increase the exercise zero alcohol, zero glue to zero dairy could a coffee animal cause bowel blockage I have breast cancer and also have Crohn's disease with significant scar tissue on the right side just among my hip bone this is where the blockage is occur
I've started coffee animals and feel good directly following but the last three times I did an animal I had a blockage later in the day you did or the following day last night the blockage lasts 12 hours is this just correlation I don't know I mean it's certainly possible I mean you think could the coffee animals cause a blockage in somebody who does it have ulcerative colitis or Crohn's disease probably known but you have an underlying damage to the tissue
yes anything is possible and the only I think of the mechanism of action of that is if you're talking about the blockage on the right side meaning the ascended colon then if the person was semi dehydrated in the coffee and then you lost some water then that would decrease the amount of fluid in the bowel
and that's where it could cause blockage especially if you already had a decreased size limit because of damage to the walls of the colon walls so I think that would be the mechanism of action if you want to continue coffee animals I would try to really ramp up the water intake your water consumption see if that makes a different maybe also increase magnesium
because that will help draw water to the colon so you increase water intake you might just absorb it and then pee it out if you increase magnesium along with it you will draw water back to the colon and see if that makes a difference otherwise I would just go off the coffee animals
you know it is possible that coffee is a food product that a person can have antibodies to too so doing a Cyrix 10 can show that if you have antibodies to coffee it's not that's not super common but it's not rare by any stretch of the imagination that could be a possible mechanism of action as well
I understand that late-stage cancers can cause blood clots some MD say the clots usually present with people who don't know that they have late-stage cancer so it could be this first side of late-stage cancer the person that know it your protocol is account for this shouldn't be concerned
well most of my understanding is that late-stage cancers really don't cause the blood clots most of the time it's the medical treatment with the medications that cause the blood clots many chemotherapies have blood clots as the side effects and other immunotherapies have blood clots as the side effects especially immunotherapies can cause inflammation anywhere and can cause inflammatory reaction in blood itself
so if you are doing certain medical procedures yes that can be a side effect personally we don't see that in our practice very much I don't think I've ever seen that in my practice so and maybe a patient had to tell me about it but that's certainly possible too
if a person has blood clots or the possibility of blood clots I really like the second part of this question would people benefit from an enzyme like lumbar chytase
so yes lumbar chytase and nano chytase would be my first goal too so that's what I'm recommending when people are trying to detox from the COVID vaccination or despite proteins that they are
have received from people that are vaccinated in or the spike proteins from the virus itself is using lumbar chytase and nano chytase because blood clots are what of the major side effects from the vaccine and cardiovascular damage
that affected us read an article about what the spike proteins do to the neurodegenerative process, not just in the brain, not just central nervous system, neurodegeneration, the peripheral system, neurodegeneration and how research began a number of years even before all this growth of virus break out
probably that they could actually use a virus, meaning the SARS COVID virus to transmit the spike proteins in order to produce such an event, neurodegeneration, very interesting.
What would be the treatment for it from a natural perspective would be lumbar chytase and nano chytase, there's some other things too, certainly garlic you'd think of that as well, maybe omega fish around as well.
Fred to mind was this diagnosed with blood clots, he has stage 4 cancer, those would be the things that I would think of.
I know that I have circulated to ourselves already in my system, but I was wondering if I had my two centimeter breast tumor removed, will that lessen the amount of circulated to themselves that would break away from the main tumor since the main tumor would be done. God, I really don't want to have a lump back to me.
However, if it will increase my survival rate, I would.
The answer is yes, for the theoretical perspective, yes, absolutely, if you remove the tumor, then you're going to certainly have less circulated tumor cells, but the reality answer is,
that does not mean that the person, just because you have less circulated tumor cells, because you remove the tumor does not mean that you're out of the woods for the tassysis to break the bad news, but long before you're even diagnosed with the breast tumor, it was already giving it off, circulating to ourselves.
But let's be wise, if we got rid of it, could we help improve the situation? The answer is from the theoretical perspective perspective, and from being a, right?
But as I'd say, absolutely, I think that might be a very good idea, and certainly doing a lump back to me while the tumor is still very small, you know, can be a good thing.
So I would not necessarily be afraid of doing that can be a very wise decision.
It's a long fasting with veggie juices, or tea, five days or more help kill a cancer.
Yes, no, possibly, I mean, we can't make gross answers to that, because we just don't know, I mean, you know, we can say that the research shows that, you know, complete water fasting over 24 hours increases idea.
One level, so that's probably not a good idea, but that's not what the question is, it's using vegetable juices and, and different teas, but they're fasting from, from solid foods.
And that can be a good thing, but some people could actually be a bad thing, because vegetable juices tend to be hot, watch higher in glucose, and that might not be a good thing.
So I don't like to take dogmatic positions and something like this, because, you know, somebody might say, well, that's the cure for cancer, you just need to go on a vegetable juice fast and fast for excellent days, and it's going to cure cancer and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Like, as handling people do that, because it just shows, you know, they're partly there, it's security, and I get that, you know, that, oh, it worked for me, so if it worked for me, it works for everybody.
Well, it doesn't work for everybody, doing vegetable juices, yes, you're pre-digesting that food, but it is much higher in glucose, and some people with really damaged guts, even though it's pre-digested.
It's still, still vegetable juice is hard to absorb, you still have to break it down just because you've done the digestive process that maybe is done at your mouth and your stomach.
If you have a deficiency in digestive enzymes and things where you have a damaged gut, drinking juice can be really hard on it.
So some people with a really damaged gut, you have to have them eat soup, but you cooked these things down, yeah, you lost a lot of the nutrients, but you're at least you can absorb the nutrients that you are consuming versus, I've had people try a veggie juice diet like this, and it just literally goes right through them and even causes more damage to their gut.
So everybody's different. If you feel lend to that, and you feel like this is what you're supposed to do, I don't want to discourage you, but I can't give you for sure answer that you might be looking for.
This from the chat is red and infrared light also good without the sauna. Yes, it is. Yes. So absolutely. So infrared is good and red light and different light therapy is good for you as well. So yes.
So I spoke to my functional doctor today to ask for another round of blood tumor markers.
I last had them in February. They have always been normal. I am stage one lobular breast cancer.
He said changes would show up in imaging way before the tumor markers, no need to do those more than once per year, unless imaging shows changes.
So by tumor markers turned positive, that would lead cancer is no longer localized and thus essentially curable with surgery, but is then system, but is then systemic and we start talking about life expectancy is pushing hard for surgery for my stage one not guaranteed a cure, but with lifestyle changes.
I mean, he says chances of reoccurrence would be statistically very small. So I don't agree with everything that that doctor says, you can show tumor markers long before you show anything else.
I said, you could never show tumor markers, even if the cancer and growing like crazy, it still might be normal within with the tumor markers spectrum.
And I would say no, that is definitely not true. The tumor markers only show up if it's metastasized. There's absolutely, I don't know where people that will go, but, but, yeah, so I ask them for where they got that data because I want to see this like that.
Can chlorophyll increase red blood cells and oxygen in the body?
Again, chlorophyll is good as violence key later. It's good for the liver. It's good for detox pathways. Will it increase red blood cells? I don't know. I haven't seen any data or that will it increase oxygen in the body? I don't know that either I don't know if that's true.
What is the physiological benefit of coffee enemies? So the physiological benefit of coffee enemies is primarily is that you're stimulating the parasympathetics. That's the primary reason why you do coffee enemies to stimulate your parasympathetic fear of a system.
You're doing all sorts of chemical things to stimulate your immune system, taking supplements, changed by diet. You do things from a emotional standpoint to stimulate your immune system, thinking positive thoughts and getting rid of negativity in your life, getting rid of negative people in your life, you're meditating on positive things, etc.
Well, neurologically, what stimulates your immune response, your parasympathetics. So most time that's ignored, you know, to neurology of everything, it tends to be ignored at one's own peril.
So coffee enemies helps stimulate the vagal nerve. That's your cranial nerve 10, which is your main stimulant of your immune function. So yes, that coffee enemies have other benefits that can help kind of hurt your gut helps with maybe wild constipation possibly, but that's not what we did coffee enemies. You do coffee enemies stimulates your immune system.
Also, your detoxification pathways are controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system. So you're helping with detoxification. So coffee enemies are helping stimulate the parasympathetics, which are stimulating the immune system function, which are stimulating parasympathetic function, which is also helping with your mood, because your parasympathetics call you decreased stress, call your brain.
Your brain would be another thing for neurological central nervous system, degeneration, in brain inflammation, coffee enemies are great for brain inflammation, help decrease brain inflammation.
Lots of good things with formulas by functional doctor also recommends a gcgm glucose monitor to confirm that my diet is lovely, no insulin glucose spikes, and that's helping starve the cancer, though my cancer is fed by dairy, no sugar, still worthwhile.
Possibly, yeah, I mean, help you with different things to see where your blood glucose is. There's always benefit to that. You can certainly just go get a little monitor from target and do a fingerprint monitor of your glucose.
Understanding glucose levels is a little bit of a learning curve. You will get a glucose spike after you eat anything, even if it's not a lot of sugar or carbohydrates in them, but it should come fairly down to normal within about two hours post your meal.
But there's benefit to that. Yes, really, I think there's really real big benefit in measuring your glucose is if you have a history of diabetes or if you have a history.
You know, syndrome acts, which is prediabetic condition that you and now you're dealing with cancer and you want to keep a closer eye on that.
Any other questions?
Zero, zilch.
All right, well, then we will call it a night. Thank you for showing it up today.
This is helpful, and I will get this up this site.
Very soon.
And no, I'll be praying for all of you. Love you all. Have a great rest of the week. Bye-bye.